cabinet ministers leaving down in street
tonight after an emergency political
meeting to discuss a human tragedy
any decisions made time for talking
running out the loss of life in the
channel a catalyst to act the pm
determined
this disaster
underscores how dangerous it is to cross
the channel in this way and it also
shows how vital it is that we now step
up our efforts to break the business
model of the gangsters who are sending
people to sea
in this way now is the time for us all
to step up to work together to do
everything we can to break these gangs
who are literally getting away with
murder the operation that's been
conducted by our friends on the on the
beaches supported as you know with uh 54
million pounds from the from the uk to
to help patrol the beaches all the
technical support that
we've been given we've been giving they
haven't been enough
nowhere near enough with record
crossings this year desperate people
taking a perilous journey today these
migrants made it to the kent coast
children swaddled in blankets the
weather worsening the crossing more
treacherous the government asking for
more patrols on french beaches the
opposition asking our own government to
do more the prime minister said earlier
that he sort of implied that the french
hadn't perhaps
been as helpful as they could have been
in trying to stop these boats being
launched do you agree with him i do
worry when the government constantly
blames others for what is happening
because i think the government the home
secretary the prime minister do need to
take responsibility
for doing all they can to prevent people
risking their lives in these most
dangerous sea lanes on the english
channel
the problem of migrant sea crossings has
bedeviled down in street for months
indeed one cabinet minister told me back
in july that it was the issue that they
were most worried about in part because
of the cut through it has with the
public but also because it is so very
difficult to resolve well they were
right to worry as today those dangerous
crossings took on a truly tragic turn
putting immense pressure on both london
and paris to act
that pressure keenly felt by the pm and
home secretary who have long campaigned
on tackling uncontrolled immigration it
was central to their 2019 general
election campaign and central to their
vote leave mission 2. conservative
politicians know their mandate rests on
it
but now the focus is less on controlling
borders and more on saving lives
there is always a big debate about open
borders about immigration and so on
today is about how you save people from
drowning at sea this is a wake-up call
this is an absolutely tragic event and a
fresh approach is clearly needed this
cannot continue
dozens more migrants arriving today on
the kent coast policing this route so
difficult the government said it would
make this passage unviable instead it
has become not just the main route of
entry but one of the deadliest two